- Hi everyone, Sal here with
my three year old son, Azad
and we're excited to announce
the launch of Khan Academy
Kids, which is designed to take
students like Azad ages 2-5
to become lifelong learners.
- Hi friend, welcome to my room.
- [Sal] Kids love this program
because it's really fun.
- Awesome!
- [Sal] Friendly characters
like our narrator, Kody Bear--
- Welcome to Khan Academy Kids.
- [Sal] Interact with them throughout the
learning experience.
And we've combined tasks
like math and reading with
activities like drawing and story telling.
We really think parents and
teachers are going to love
Khan Academy Kids because
it's aligned with important
standards, like common core
and the Headstarts Learning
Outcome's framework.
There are thousands of
activities and original books in
the program.
Khan Academy Kids also promotes
social emotional development
through topics like empathy and sharing.
And what's more, we've partnered
with Super Simple songs,
Bellwether Media, and National
Geographic Young Explorer
magazine to provide learning
materials kids will love.
Khan Academy Kids is a free
mobile app available in the App
Store, Google Play, and Amazon.
Download today, let the
joyful learning begin!
(children laughing)
Hi everyone, Sal here.
I'm here to announce--
(child squeals)
(children laughing)
Shh.
Hi everyone, I'm here with my
son Azad, who's three years
old, to announce the launch
of Khan Academy Kids, which is
designed--
(child squeals)
(child laughing)
Kids 2-5 ready to become
learners for life.
(child chattering)
Say it loud and funny!
- Download today!
- Download today and let
the joyful learning begin!
(child squeals)
How do they do this in movies?
(child laughing)